大暴落のきっかけは何かと言うと円安なん
ですよ円安に備えるっていうのはまず第1
段階だと思います国内のそのちょ直外
ルートうんうん契約農家それから契約漁業
っていうのは増やしてると今うちがやっ
てることですなるほどこれ絶対大事なこと
です大暴落が来ると何が起きるかって言う
と世の中のマーケットが半分になるんです
よ今からマーケットが半分になるんだから
うん選ばれる店を作ることなんですよあだ
どこにその差別あるのかわざわざ選んで
もらうためにはどうしたらいいのかどこに
でもある居酒屋じゃダメなんですよそう
ですねうん選んでもらわないとうんそれと
今からどうやって損益分岐を落とすのか
損益分岐を落とすには固定費下げることと
あとは生産戦上げるしかないんですよ外食
なんてのはQSCしかないんですからQ
商品ねSサービスCクレスこれしかないん
ですよなるほどQSCでいかにバリューを
高めるかこれはもう何千点あろうが1点あ
か全く一緒ですお客様はそのバリューが
高ければ使ってくれるんですバリューが
低ければ使わないただそんな簡単なことな
んです
うん渡辺美希さん今その渡海の循環のああ
はいはいはいはいこれも本当にすごい
なんて言うのかな新しいやっぱりこの
モデルを自分で考えていきますたよねはい
はい考ましたこの辺のとこちょっと話して
もらい
ます政治にになってねうん政治っていうの
はその法と税制で世の中変るんですよそれ
以外ないんですねだ政治家っていうのは
一貫どんな法律を作るのかそれからどう
いう税制を取ってどういう予算の使い方を
するのかこれしか実仕事ないんですよ他ろ
なことないんですねだからま余計なお金
使ったりするわけですけどで僕はその税と
法律っていうのは国を動かすというのは
もう実感してましたはいでしかしま足らず
でえ政治家をもうやめようと思ったわけ
ですがその時にじゃ経営は何で社会を
変えるんだろうかって考えてんですよその
時にあ経営はモデルで変えられると思った
んですよなるほどなるほどモデルで変え
られるんですよなんでかと言うと僕は介護
やりましたうんあの渡海の介護うちの介護
というのはあの本当にそういう面からと
異常な介護だったんですようんそれ何かと
言うとオムはつけないって方針を持ってた
んですね例えば色はさせないとはい更うん
それから車椅は載せないはいそれから機械
欲には入れないっていうそのあの時の介護
の常識を全部覆したんですようん結果とし
てあの介護の経営者の方からまさん切れ
ことばっかりたら潰れるからねえあんたに
やってることは儲かんないことばっかり
じゃないかえそういう問題じゃないんだと
いうにま言われていやむしろ僕がうんこの
うんやりたい介護をやって潰れるんだっ
たらもういいと仕方ないとうんなぜならば
僕は自分の親が入ったらどうしたいかて
ことでやってるわけだからねその車椅子に
ねすぐ乗せる車椅乗せた方が1人が3人
年度見れるんですよでもマンツーマンなっ
たら動き始めるわけだからそそうでしょだ
から例えば車椅子にうん乗せちゃうと楽だ
から今度乗るんですよなるほどでも車椅に
乗るとあっという間に健康状態悪くなって
わけですよ動しなくなるからなるほど
なるほどだ親だったらきついこと言ってて
も車椅乗せたくないででしょということで
車椅から乗ってる人さも立たせよってのは
僕の大方針だったんですよなるほどうんで
まその時にそんなおきれ事言ってたら
潰れるよって言われたんですがうんうん
結果としてですね今日本中の介護は渡海の
介護の真似してるんですよええつまりどう
いうことかって言ったら渡の介護はすごい
人気が出ましたなんであんな人気出るん
だろうあこんなことやってるからだ大変だ
けどやってみようていうことでこの渡の
介護のモデルが全体のうんになることに
よって良くなったはい全体がということは
ですね経営っていうのはモデルで社会変え
られるなとま思ってで僕はそれでえ国会
議員の後にも1回経営者やろうとうんうん
えま29年僕は経営者やって6年間政治家
だったんですがもう29年やってそモデル
で世の中書いてみようとは僕の野望なわけ
ですうんでそれは何かと言と単なるま一次
産業2次産業3次産業だけじゃなくてうん
まあ有機農業それから工場まサービス業
ですうんじそれをこれからの子供たちの
ことを考えて循環型で全部やろうじゃない
うんでなおかつこれは自然エネルギーを
使おうじゃないなるほどだから自然
エネルギーを使った循環型の6次産業
モデルというものをうんわモデルと呼んで
これを世界中に広めていこうこれができ
たら未来の子供たちからきっとありがと
うって言ってもらえるんだというに思い
まし
[音楽]
たやっぱりその本質を本気で追求すると
本物になると僕はずっとこれを自分の1つ
の生き方として大事にしてきたんですその
本質とは何かと言うとみきさんと話して
いつも思うことなんですけどやっぱ黄金率
ああそうですね相手の立場に立って考えて
ますよねうんそうですねこれ何をするにも
一貫してるんじゃないですかあのお店を1
店舗目からお店をやってね24の時に1
店舗作ったわけですよねうんその時にま
本当に店作ったわけですよはいその時の
原則は1つだけなんですよそれは何かつ
たらもし自分がお客様だったらうんしたい
ことを徹底的にやろうとなるほどだから常
に今何ができるんだろうって考え続けまし
たよね例えばあ熱いものを熱く出るのは
当たり前だしそれから例えばトイレが綺麗
で鼻が飾ったのも当たり前だし雨の日には
ねタオルを貸してあげるとかそれから急に
降ってきたら傘は差し上げとかね例えば
うんはいうんま高級クラブならどこでも
やってることです簡単うんそれはそうです
ねそううんうんうん高級クラブでやってる
ことを居酒屋でやったらどうだろうかうん
うんいうことで居酒屋でやったら本当に超
繁盛店になりましたしなるまその後介護は
先ほど言ったように自分の父は親なという
気持ちだったりうんうんもう会社も同じな
んですよもし自分が社員だったらどういう
会社で会ってほしいかないう風に思って僕
は社員と接してますしなるほど
常にもう一貫してますねうんも病院もあれ
なんですよ経営してあの赤字の病院をすぐ
黒人したんですようんうんこれも同じうん
うん学校も同じうんうんだ僕はね平という
ことにおいて黄金率があって経営があって
黄金率があるでしょあとはいろんなこと
やってるけども全部1つなんですようん
うんいや僕はもう学校のことはねびっくり
したの校長やってるってことなんだよね
普通ね理事長はやってるってのはもうよく
分かるけど校長までやってるってのはそこ
にどれだけ本気かってことですよね昨日も
事業やりましたよあそうなん毎週今事業
やったんです毎週行ってま先生たち指導し
てそれから毎週事業やってんですよその
毎週の昨日毎週やってる事業の内容は論語
とそれが日経新聞あ今日の日経新聞は開け
てこらんとまこことこいたねま先週なんか
だったあれかな出生率だったのかな昨日は
あれたまたま日経新聞に百貨点の本合と
いう特集があったんですじゃあ百貨点って
いうのはこれからどうなると思うってこと
をずっとこう話をして百貨点の役割ってん
だと思うとか百貨点ってなんで水したんだ
とかそういう話をずっと事業の中でやって
いってはいそういうことやってます校長
先生とし
てこれからね大暴落のが来るまこれ
おそらく
さんが断うんうん
くるえやっぱり自分自身がどれだけの人間
力どれだけの軽力をしっかりとやはり備え
でまず持っておいてうん危機的状況の中で
もより良い選択ができるように備えなきゃ
いけないそうですねそれと実際のそのお金
をですねまドルに変えるとかまそういう
ことはもちろんあると思うんですけれども
なんかね私こう世の中見ててね勉強熱心な
経営者はどんどん良くなるんだけどうん
そうですねうん勉強しない人はどんどん
なんかこう時代の流れに負けていってる
あの本当にこの勉強熱心っっていうのは
簡単に言うけど1番大事なことだと思うん
ですけど大だどう思いますその番大事だと
思います勉強の1番のま我々みたいな経営
者が勉強する勉強っていうのはうん他の人
は経験したことを験することなんですよね
うんうんだから多くの方が例えばこんな
失敗したこんなことあったとかから例えば
こういう考え方のこういう例えばあま論理
的な考え方があるえそれを身につつける
ことによって境い方っていうのはいくつも
広がるんですよね1個しか武器持って
なかったら1個の戦い方しかできないじゃ
ないですか勉強ってのは武器ですからはい
うん100の勉強したら100の戦い方が
できるんですよねそうですそれはきて
なおかつプラス経営ってのは変化対応
本様だったら懐の中にたくさんの武器を
持ってた方が強いに決まってますよ本当
そう思いますこ本当いい経営者だなと思っ
ても勉強しない人は止まりますねもしくは
ダメになりますねうんそうです
[音楽]
ねまだ本当はもう3日でも4日でも語り泣
たいぐらいなんですけども時間も限られ
てるのでえこれ最後にねさんがこれから
目指してるものやYouTubeを見て
くださってる方へのメッセージをさ
ちょっとお願いします大暴落っていう本を
ねあの本当に1人でも多くの方に読んで
いただきたいなていう風に思っています
あの先日もですね僕のラジオでですねま
その世の中の人に大暴落来ると思いますか
というそういうまアンケート思ったんです
ねそうすると世の中の人が2割ぐらいの人
がねやっぱりはい日本の国のお金の使い方
ってめちゃくちゃだし日本の国の借金って
うんもう天文学的だよねみたいなことは2
割ぐらいに人8割ぐらいの人は何言う
かっていうといやそう言ったって経済
うまく言ってんじゃないそうは言ったって
ね定よくなってるんじゃないっていう8割
ぐらいの人を発言を聞くとですねうんうん
うんエビデンスが何もないんですなるほど
込つなんとなくなんとなく日本がえ日本が
潰れるってあるわけないじゃんとかいや縁
がみくあるわけないじゃんていう風に思っ
てるだけなんですようんうんだから僕は
そのラジオでも言ったんですけど是非現実
を見てくれとうん今ねこの日銀がどういう
状況なのかとそして政府がどういう状況な
のかと僕は国会金に立ったんだからなか
知ってるからだから潰れるって言ってんだ
から潰れますようん今のまま行けばうんね
だからそういう現実を皆さん見て解放して
くださいとだつまさこの継承ですよ承
鳴らしたわけですからうんうんでその国会
の中身とか国会のやり取りも含めて全部
こっちには細かく入ってますはいこっち
細かいですからはいジムさんの論よりも
こっちのがこっちの論の方うんま是非あの
まこのYouTube見ていただいてる方
にですね
あの助かってほしいなジムさんの対策も
書いてありますのでこの中にジムさんは
そのためにどうしてるか僕もどうしてる
かって全部書いてありますので是非読んで
いただきたいと思いますま日頃あの親しく
お付き合いしてる渡辺美さんは非常に
ポジティブなもう本当に前向き思考の塊り
ですその渡さんがあえてこの本を書いて
いる私はここにものすごくその真実みと
いうかいや本当にあの私もポジティブな
人間なのであんまりこういうネガティブ
アプローチっていうのは普段しないわけ
ですよねどうしたら良くなるかとかいや
必ず道は開けるとかあなたはあなたのまで
良いとかいろんなそういう前向き思考を
伝えてるのででもやっぱりそこは思い込み
ではなくてエビデンスとそうですね
しっかりと裏付けを取らなければならない
時代になったのかなと確かにその予兆は
ですね明らかに今よく心を沈めて見てみる
とこの政治の乱れもいろんなところから
確かに日本のですね今問題は見えてきて
ます是非皆さん今日のこのYouTube
え参考にしていただいてより良い人生を
選択してくださいどうもみさんありがとう
ございましたこちこそありがとうござい
まし
[音楽]
たミキさんがこの自分は将来社長になると
決意されてこれなぜ最初飲食業だったん
ですかうんだからそれはね22までは
決まってなかったのねで日本1周したり
世界一周したりしてうんそれでえ何をやろ
うって探して最終的に世界1周をして
ニューヨークで素晴らしい店と出会ってえ
店がにまず店のね1点対1点の戦いなだ
からそれこそ局所の戦いにランチェスター
じゃないけど局所戦に持ち込めるビジネス
しかやらないって決めてたわけなるほどで
じゃあ何があるかってことでま
コンピューターのソフトを作るとか実は
考えたるうんうんそれからいろんな小さな
まホテルみたいなとこから始めようかなと
かいろんなこと考えてる中でうん外食で
いこうんそれ22のその22歳でそこまで
考えてるっていうやっぱり戦略的なんだよ
ねだってから社長になると思ってんだから
さそれみんなは22って若いと思うかも
しれないけどもう12代勝って勝ってんだ
ねそこまでそうえどうして社長なろうと
思ったのま父の会社が潰れたそういうこと
うん父の会社が潰れて親父はものすごい
大きな会社の社長だったけど潰れて貧乏に
なってものすごい貧乏になって絶対この
貧乏乗り越えてやるそうですかへえでま
もうその時の気持ちとしては親父救って
あげたいっていうかへえま小さいながら
思っそうなんですかそうなんですかその
社長とすごく似ていらっしゃいますよねま
そうだねうんやっぱりでも経営ってね
はっきり言って一寸先は闇ですようん実際
あまり甘く考えない方がいいだからうん
経営者になっていい人生生きてる人って
いうのはみんな覚悟を持ってるしそれと
本気ですよ中途半端に甘い考え方持って経
してたらこれはもう地獄だとうんそして
本当にシビアな話だけど弱いところから
潰れてきますうん
早速最後はやっぱり本気で真剣にお客さん
のこと考えてたりえ本気で仕事考えてる
ところが最後残るんですよみきさん口癖の
ように言ってるも外食は全部なくなって俺
は最後に最後はもう俺んとこ残るって
コロナの3日に1回見せしめてる時にもね
微動せずに言ってだよね日本中に外食が
なくなった時俺の会社すで外食がなくなら
ないそうそうだから俺の会社残るそ銀行に
もて銀行笑ってたいやそれとねやっぱり
銀行が絶対に渡辺さんの会社は潰しちゃ
いけない会社だって銀行の取りから言われ
てるそういうなんだろう人だからこれが
大事だと僕は思ってるあれ
ねねありありがたいやこないだね僕
あの周年事業にはい40年40周年のええ
参加させてもらってござあそれ見て本当に
僕は感動もしたし本当に渡辺美希さんは
本物の傾斜だと思いましたそこにはね本当
に素晴らしい40年のまさにね理屈抜きの
リアルの本当に素晴らしい感動の世界が
ありました
うん私も37年なんであと3年ちょっと
頑張ります先輩です3年先輩ですはいはい
年は私のがちょっと上なんだけどね経営の
先輩ですからはい3年先輩情熱は年取ら
ないうん僕はもうこれからもねますます
頑張ります頑張りましょうお互いに
ありがとうございますはい